it's Friday and that means it's time for
Friday Follies and for that we turn to
Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Raymond Biden and Harris conducted
a campaign call with the Democrat
faithful well now while this virtual
rally avoided talk of inflation or the
Border or crime it more than made up for
it with enthusiasm watch
I could not be prouder to be a part of
this team and to be here with the
president my wife the vice president the
first lady because of your hard work you
sent me and Joe Biden to the White House
we also must clearly see the moment in
time in which we live
and I believe when you know what you
stand for you know what to fight for
on every one of these issues we know
what we stand for
we know what we fight for
and we know we're bored when we hear
things I mean this was she right is he
running the husband was Doug imhoff's
children being held off-site it seems
like an Isis video that was he looks
like the travel agent on the second
voyage of the Titanic I mean he's he's
trying to he's like I'm so excited about
this journey
someone to get beheaded there I mean
that was a horrible well and it's the
second gentleman in Kamal Allure
couldn't quite seal the deal surely Joe
Biden could bring it home
less protect a woman's right to choose
let's get Roe v Wade
it's just a long and there's so much we
have to do you know so you gotta let me
tell you something because that's so
important
let's get rovie away is that a verb now
Roe v how do you get Roe v Wade what
does that mean let's get Roe v Wade does
that mean you vanish he was much better
with the cue cards the little cheat
sheets last week I think but this if you
didn't tell me that this wasn't a parody
I would say who did this those are good
deep fakes scary all right Raymond it's
time for oh you're three wishes three
wishes anything you desire I will grab
anything and well well no I really have
to okay okay well the other day was
bring your child to work day and I saw
this disturbing video so my first wish
is what that White House staffers would
stop exposing children to Joe Biden it
upsets the kids and confuses the Biden
what was the last country you've
traveled to the last country I've
traveled I'm drinking once was the last
one I was in I I've been to 89 I met
with 89 heads and States so far so I'm
trying to think what was the last where
was the last place I was it's hard to
keep track
um I mean yeah you're right Ireland
that's where it was
how did you know that I have six
grandchildren and I'm crazy about them
and I speak to them every single day not
a joke matter of fact I just got
finished going through the calls and uh
only one of them answered the phone
right but that's what we're gonna talk
about now he actually is seven
grandchildren okay if you count Hunters
love child who by the way Hunter is
asking the court to deprive of his name
I you know I prefer to see Joe Biden on
bring your brain to work day not on
bring your child to work day it would
work out a lot what was that show are
You Smarter Than A Fifth Grader what was
it I don't know he the I think the
answer is no well we we are not but the
children were adorable right they were
pretty cute pretty smart very sweet but
he really doesn't understand when you go
to 80 you meet with 89 different heads
of state that means 89 countries is he
not does he understand that a head of
state is the head of a country this
could be the launch of a new series
presidents Say the Darndest Things
forget the kids my second wish is that
people would stop pretending to be who
they are not this man Nicholas Al
averdian is wanted in Utah and Rhode
Island on several charges of rape and
sex abuse he's a fugitive from the law
who according to authorities and media
reports faked his own death in 2020.
officials now believe he has assumed the
identity of a disabled Irish orphan
Arthur Knight Dateline caught up with Mr
Knight in Scotland
what do you say to to someone who
believes that that you are Nicholas aloe
Verdian
I am not Nicholas and I do not know how
to make this clear what do you say to
people who say these are crocodile tears
he's putting on a show this is all an
act
oh
that's a right blue
that this is so sad I mean maybe James
Corden is going back to television and
that's what this is he he is he's
allegedly faking to be someone else he's
now claiming he's an Irishman uh when
Hill well he's claiming he's disabled
even though the last time he was in the
hospital seems like a fake the
authorities matched tattoos on his arm
that's how they identified him as this
alleged sex offense Sam's telling us to
move it okay okay now we've seen a lot
of sad vocal this is my last wish we've
seen a lot of sad vocals this week Laura
from heads of state to famous actors my
final wish is that people would stop
encouraging non-singers to sing in
public as evidence here's the president
of South Korea and Tom Cruise a long
long time ago
[Applause]
[Music]
well Biden has finally realized he has
limitations but you know Laura dancers
who dance who can't dance shouldn't do
so in public singers shouldn't do it try
this with surgeons let's have a
non-surgeon go and perform your surgery
we'll see how that works Pilots we can't
fly yeah all right no fourth wish for
you no fourth wish cut me off all right
Raymond thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else